l'heure, tout le monde, les prix
des livres. Reportage.
- C'est quoi,
es libraires libraires libraire,
ça se voit, les prix
sont à la hausse
ÉRIC SIMARD, libraire,
Librairie du Square
- Oui, régulièrement,des petide.
Je le vois beaucoup,
en ce moles livres
de poche. Ça peut augmenter
d'un dollar ou deux.
- Cette inflation pourraitimpors
au Canada, Marquis Imprimeur,
a envoyé, mardi, une note
à ses clients indiquant
que le prix du papier d'édition
grimperait de 6 à 9 %
SERGE LOUBIER, prés. et chef
direction, Marquis Imprimeur
- J'ai eu plus de hausses
de papier cette année que depuis
le début de ma carrière en 1994.
Ça vous donne uen ce moment.
- En librairie, ça pourrait
se traduire par une augmentation
du prix d'environ 5 % en 2022.
ARNAUD FOULON, VP du groupe HMH,
- Dans certains cas, ça va
être des hausses s hausses s ha,
dans d'autres cas, des hausses
on peut penser que le produit
augmenter un petit peu
par rapport à ce à quoi on est
habitués, parce que ça a été
prix depuis presque 20 ans.
- Le secteur du li
en plein croissance :
en 2021, les ventes ont augmenté
à 2020, et les éditeurs
ne veulent pas freiner cet élan
avec des prix trop élevés.
- Mais un livre jeunessehabitués
à payer 19,95 $, la capacité
d'augmenter le prix est très
limitée. On passe à 20,95 $'est.
On ne peut pas le vendre
26,95 $; le marché
ne suivra pas.
- Parmi les produits culturels,
du livre qui augmentera.
Par exemple, le géant Netfliantx
a annoncé que le prix de
son forfait haute définition
Il y a aussi le disque vinyle;
le plast papier
sont plus chers.
- Une "puck" de plastique...- Ee
en utilise beaucou
Dans cette usine de pressage
une explosion des coûts
de production.
PIERRE-LUC SAVARD,
copropriegardé desegardé desega,
l'année passée, en janvier 2021,
t notre plastique
environ 1,16 $ US la livre.
On est maintenant rendus
2022. Donc, un an plus tard,
e augmentation
de 80 %
par livre.
- De retour dans les librairies,
la légère hausse du prix
outre mesure pour l'instant.
se que ça va être
subtil. Il y a des éditeurs
qui vont en profiter,es diffuset
en profiter, mais ce n'est p
dans l'intérêt du milieu
de trop en profiter.
plusieurs grands lecteurs
vous diront qu'un bon livre,
ça n'a pas de prix.
Ici Louis-Philipp